yippee ki maybe lovers it's Chan here
and today I'm breaking down the new
Incredibles 2 trailer for Pixar Easter
eggs things you might have missed plus a
theory about the villain reveal I'm also
starting a giveaway for an awesome
Incredibles 2 Funko pop you just need to
be a subscriber and leave me a comment
about the movie for a chance to win
we're going to start with the meeting at
the dev tech building were mr.
incredible Elastigirl and Frozone are
being introduced to winston Dever
remember in the sneak peek that Frozone
mentioned he'd been approached to set up
just such a meeting I was a prosperous
tycoon must to talk about Hugo stuff
notice that in this scene mr. incredible
and Elastigirl are actually wearing
their original early costumes from the
first movie before Edna mode made them
those iconic red suits were more used to
seeing them in and notice that when
Winston Dever pitches his idea to bring
the supers back into public favor he's
showing a picture of the Incredibles
family being led away by a police
officer for in the background of the
picture it looks like it might be during
the aftermath of the under- rampage
there seems to be a lot of public damage
and destruction that happens during the
Incredibles fight with the Underminer
and it sounds like public opinion might
be quite anti supers even if the PAR
family did take down the villain there
are also some very cool action shots in
the new trailer and I want to look
particularly at this shot of - the young
speedster is running through portals
that take him through solid objects I
think this could be the work of a new
character called void who according to
the official description for her
character has the ability to diverse and
manipulate objects around her
by creating void to allow the objects to
appear and disappear Boyd hasn't shown
up yet in the trailers but her character
description also states she's a wannabe
super and mega fan of Elastigirl but
what's also interesting in this scene is
that - appears to be running in a
never-ending loop you can see an image
of - running through the same portal
over and over in the distance now
judging by Boyd's character description
it sounds like she'd be friendly to our
band of superheroes but what if she's
actually a villain in disguise
masquerading as a fan of Elastigirl
could she have trapped - in an endless
loop of sorts or maybe she is really on
their side and created this loop
so dentally a possible alternative is
that these portals are being created by
Jack Jack who has a ton of superpowers
in fact we've already seen him teleport
himself before now including in another
scene in this trailer and I wonder if
like me those scenes made you think of
it at the Newsom's
Lincoln x-men Days of Future past and
also vibe in TVs the flash it also looks
like violets is getting some new powers
in the sequel to go with her adolescent
angst as well as being able to create
forcefield energy shields that can
protect her family there's a moment
during what looks like the under-
sequence where she seems to cast force
blades or blasts that take out a piece
of falling rubble saving the people
below okay let's get to the big villain
reveal from the trailer it looks like
his dastardly plan will be hypnotizing
in mind controlling people via their TV
screens Elastigirl already seems to be
aware of his plan as notice how she's
shielding her eyes from the screens in
the background here this is happening at
the local TV station and I think this is
going to tie in with the scene earlier
in the trailer or Elastigirl attacks in
escaping helicopter a recent Incredibles
2 Lego sent as an Elastigirl rooftop
pursuit scene which shows that screens
labor is indeed the person piloting the
helicopter which also has a spinning
hypno propeller that can hypnotize you
if you look at it and there's some
evidence now which I think tie screens
labor with the head of the deaf tech
corporation Winston Dever firstly the
shape of screen sleepers head seems to
match that of Winston's and secondly
think about what business death Tex
involved in it's a telecommunications
company in fact the Lego set mentions
that screens flavor is trying to hack
into a satellite dish on the roof of a
building and that Lego set building is
likely the same TV building as in the
trailer on top of that Winston has a
sister called Evelyn who's the tech
brainchild behind the business what's
more as I mentioned in my breakdown of
the Olympics trailer
Everland ever could be pronounced evil
endeavor even if that is a little on the
nose all of which gives me the
impression that these two could be up to
no good there's also something fishy
about the tycoon
plan to recruit Elastigirl and as a
possible hint at that in the recent Edna
mode teaser
I'm not all dark in HD and Elastigirl
Edna designed No some guy named
Alexander gal Blackie
I'm not sure if all these evil hints and
links to dev tech feel a little too
obvious so perhaps there'll be a further
twist in the movie a bit like we got
with cocoa but at the moment I'm
definitely guessing some dodgy vibes
from Winston by the way it looks like
this scene is happening in the city of
new urban as you can spot part of a sign
for a new urban savings and loans bank
in the distance new urban is a new
location that we introduced in
Incredibles to there are also some Pixar
Easter eggs and callbacks in the trailer
which I want to talk about all
vegetables I did the shot of a mountain
of broccoli on Dash's plate as he
complains about his mum ordering a
vegetable takeout dish is a hat tip to
inside out and Riley's a version to
eating that particular vegetable hold on
guys it's probably well I just saved our
lives
yeah you're welcome and those Chinese
takeout containers are also another
Pixar Easter Egg as the same style of
food box has been used a number of times
in other Pixar movies the first time was
in a bug's life where it was called the
Chinese cabinets of metamorphosis it
also appeared in the Pizza Planet truck
in Toy Story 2 in Linguini's apartment
in ratatouille and it was also an
inside-out word just like the paw family
Riley and the Andersons sat down for
dinner a Chinese takeout one of the most
memorable moments in the first movie was
when Frozone went to get his super suit
so he could join the fight against
Syndrome and then this happened
where's my supersuit so it was just
fantastic to discover that this time
he's got his suit at the ready although
by the sound of it his wife honey still
isn't overly keen on her husband's
superhero shenanigans suit up
it might get weird I'll be there now
what do you think about the new
Incredibles 2 trailer and do you have
any theories on the villain or was there
anything else I missed be sure to
subscribe and leave me a comment for
your chance to win an awesome
Incredibles 2 Funko pop the winner of my
art of Coco Pixar giveaway is on screen
right now so if that's you private
message me with your details and I'll
get back to you if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a like and you can tap
the screen for my latest Pixar and
Disney videos thanks for watching and
see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers